in this video we're going to be going
through an algebra Readiness review and
practice we're going to be going through
58 examples and I encourage you to try
to do these problems on your own just
like you're taking a quiz or a test and
see what areas you're strong in weaken
maybe things you need to practice a
little bit more these are all the
different concepts that we're going to
be going through and I encourage you to
try to do this without a calculator as
much as possible and a few of the
problems you'll need a calculator it'll
be helpful and it will be allowed but
try to do as much as you can without but
we're going to be going through positive
and negative numbers order of operations
evaluating expressions fraction
operations decimal operations exponents
absolute value distributive property
solving equations inequalities writing
sentences as equations and inequalities
proportions and percentages the greatest
common factor least common multiple and
some perimeter and area problems so it's
a real good sampling of important things
that you're going to need to know as you
go into like an algebra course so let's
Dive In and let's get some practice so
you might want to pause the video and
try some of these problems so this first
section is talking all about the
positive and negative numbers so how
would you do these problems right here
go ahead and pause the video try it on
your own
now if I was going to do it number one
negative 7 plus 12. well when you're
adding a positive and negative number
together what you want to do is you want
to figure out which one's larger is the
positive one larger or is the negative
one larger and then you want to ask
yourself how much larger so in this case
you can see we've got 12 plus negative
seven we've got more positive numbers
than negative numbers how many more five
more so this is going to be positive 5.
another way that I kind of like to
explain it to students is that if you're
walking forward 12 steps and you walk
backwards seven steps where are you in
relation to where you started are you
further ahead are you further behind
Okay let's go to number two now negative
5 minus negative eight what did you get
for this problem
well when you see a subtraction you can
always change it into an addition
problem by adding the opposite so you
change that subtraction to addition you
change the second number to the opposite
sign so if it's positive you make it
negative if it's negative you make it
positive and then it's just like the
previous problem you look at okay I've
got a negative and a positive number do
I have more positives or more negatives
looks like we have more positives how
many more three more so it's positive
three okay let's look at number three
now ten minus sixteen what did you get
for that one
well again you can see we're subtracting
subtractions like adding the opposite
and I've got more negatives now than
positives how many more negatives I've
got six more negatives this is going to
be a negative 6.
okay for number four now you can see
these two numbers are right next to one
another with nothing in between that
means that they're multiplied together
so when you have a negative times a
negative what do you get you're going to
get a positive and 4 times 7 is 28. so
if you need to go back and practice all
your multiplication tables go ahead and
do that that's certainly important but
as far as the rules if you have a
positive times a positive that's what
we're used to that's just a positive
number but if you have a negative times
a positive or vice versa a positive
times a negative you're going to get a
negative and then if you have a negative
positive
so one way students sometimes like to
remember it is if the signs are the same
either both positive or both negative
it's going to be positive but if they're
opposite then it's going to be negative
and the rules for division are exactly
the same so two positives you get a
positive a positive and negative you get
a negative two negatives if you're
dividing you would get a positive so
it's easy to remember multiplication
division through the same rules now for
number five what do you think for this
one a negative 84 divided by 12. well we
have a negative divided by a positive so
we know this is going to be negative and
12 goes into 84 seven times
for number six now negative five times
eight you can see these are multiplied
they're right next to each other a
negative times a positive is a negative
and we know five times eight is forty so
that's a negative forty and the last one
here for the pauses and negatives is a
negative 48 divided by a negative eight
we have a negative divided by a negative
which is a positive and 8 goes into
forty eight six times so this is a
positive 6.
okay and these next group of problems
we're going to be talking about the
order of operations sometimes you know
this as the PEMDAS or that please excuse
my dear Aunt Sally or just basically
knowing what to do first second third
fourth like that so see if you can pause
the video and do these four problems on
your own and we'll go through them
together
so if I was going to do this first one
here number eight I would think of that
PEMDAS and so what is the PEMDAS let's
write it down here it's parentheses
exponents multiplication and division
addition and subtraction so it's kind of
like four levels of importance so we're
going to start inside of the parentheses
first now inside of the parentheses
we're still going to pay attention to
the order of operations you know are
there any additional parentheses are
there any exponents is there any
multiplying and dividing okay yeah
multiplying dividing so let's do that
first so 2 divided by 2 is 1.
foreign
okay now we're still inside of the
parentheses so let's go ahead and finish
that so 4 plus 1 is going to be 5.
notice I'm bringing down everything and
then now when we look at this we say
okay is there any uh
exponents no is there any multiplying or
dividing well you can see these are next
to each other that means that they're
multiplied together so let's do that
next that's 35.
okay and now let's see we've got
addition and subtraction we can see we
still have subtraction in addition you
want to work from left to right so 3
minus 35 remember we subtract it's like
adding the opposite so that's 3 plus
negative 35 which is negative 32
plus 1 and you can see at negative 32
plus 1 is just equal to a negative 31
and that's our final answer
okay let's go to number nine now so
again following the PEMDAS are there any
parentheses no are there any exponents
yes we've got an exponent here and an
exponent here so 2 cubed means 2 times 2
times 2 3 times that's going to give us
8.
and 1 squared that's 1 times 1 which is
1. okay now let's see there's
multiplying and dividing yep we've got
these are multiplied these are
multiplied 3 times 8 is 24. 4 times 1 is
4 and now we're just left with addition
subtraction okay 24 minus 4 is a 20 and
we got it
okay let's go on over to number 10 what
did you get on this one again following
the PEMDAS are there any parentheses no
are there any exponents no is there any
multiplying and dividing yes 16 divided
by 4 is 4.
okay now we're down to addition
subtraction we want to work from left to
right six minus four is two and two plus
three is five and you got it last order
of operation one number 11 what did you
get on this one you can see we have a
fraction which is kind of like a
division problem you can treat the
numerator and denominator like two
separate groups so I would simplify this
numerator here
here we'll just circle it three plus
seven is ten and I would simplify this
denominator here 5 minus 3 is 2. and
then you can almost think of it like
parentheses like you would do that part
first and then you say okay is there any
exponents is there any multiplying and
dividing yes this fraction bar means
like division or dividing so 10 divided
by 2 is 5.
and 5 minus 4 is 1. and you got it
okay now moving on to evaluating
expressions now evaluate means like find
the value and we're given that x equals
3 and Y equals negative 2 and Z is equal
to 5. see if you can pause the video and
do number 12 13 and 14 see what you get
when you find the value or evaluate now
if I was going to do number 12 what I'm
going to do is if I know X is 3 I'm
going to substitute 3 in place of X I'm
going to substitute negative 2 in place
of Y
and then we replace Z with 5. okay so
following our PEMDAS just like we were
doing in the last segment we're going to
start inside the parentheses when I
subtract it's like adding the opposite
so 3 minus negative 2 is like 3 plus 2
so that's 5 and then you can see these
are next to each other that means
they're multiplied together 5 times 5 is
25. sometimes when you're doing the
substituting it's good to just put the
quantity in parentheses so you treat it
like a group
so for number 13 now what did you get
for this one we've got Y which is
negative 2
raised to the X power which we know X is
three
minus Z which is equal to 5. so again
you could put it in parentheses
sometimes I like to do that if it's a
negative number just to capture the
whole thing as a group so here we've got
a negative 2 cubed that means a negative
2 times a negative 2 times a negative 2
3 times 3 negatives is going to come out
to a negative so if it's an odd number
of negatives you're going to get a
negative if you have an even number of
negatives it'll be a positive and
negative 8 minus 5. again remember when
we subtract it's like adding the
opposite a negative 8 plus a negative 5
is a negative 13. again it's kind of
like walking backwards eight steps plus
another five steps your 13 steps back
from where you started and then number
14 now we've got negative three
2 times x which is equal to three
minus Z which is equal to five
so again starting inside the parentheses
let's see 2 times 3 is 6.
still inside the parentheses six minus
five is one
these two guys are next to each other
that means they're multiplied together
so negative 3 times 1 is negative 3 and
you got it okay now moving on to
operations with fractions like adding
subtracting multiplying dividing also
some mixed numbers in here see if you
can pause the video and do these
problems on your own without a
calculator and see what you get now if I
was going to do number 15
what I would do is I would think about
getting common denominators so I can see
I've got a 3 and a 9 so I say well
what's the smallest number that 3 and 9
both go into well that would be nine so
this one's already nine what can I do to
make this one nine I could multiply the
denominator by three but if I do that I
have to multiply the numerator by 3
because 3 divided by 3 is 1 and 1 times
this fraction doesn't change the value
of it it just changes the way that it
looks so that gives us 6 over 9
minus one over nine which is equal to 5
over 9 or 5 9. so that's the key you
want to get a common denominator when
you're adding or subtracting fractions
okay now for number 16 we've got some
mixed numbers here five and one-half
minus one and one-fourth sometimes what
I like to do with these types of
problems is instead of looking at it
horizontally like this I like to write
it vertically so I'm going to say five
and one half
minus 1 and 1 4 and then what we're
going to do is we're going to subtract
down now when I look at the one-half and
the one-fourth again I want to get a
common denominator so I say well two and
four they both go into four so let me
multiply this fraction by two over two
that's going to give me
two-fourths so I'll just cross that out
now so I have 5 and 2 4 minus 1 and 1 4
2 4 minus 1 4 is going to be two minus
one that's one over four you keep the
denominator you just subtract the
numerators and then five minus one is
four so we're getting four and one
fourth
okay for number 17 now what did you get
for this one
so we're moving on to some division now
when you divide fractions sometimes
students remember that keep it change it
flip it so you keep the first one just
as it is
and you change the division to
multiplication and then you flip or take
the reciprocal of the second fraction
the one you're dividing by now you can
multiply the numerators together in
denominators together and reduce but
sometimes what's helpful is to do what
we call uh kind of pre-reducing or cross
canceling so for example I can reduce
anything that's in the numerator with
anything that's in the denominator
on the diagonals or or above one another
so for example the 7 and the 21 7 goes
in here once 7 goes in here three times
over here four goes in here negative one
time and 4 goes in here two times now
when I multiply across I get negative 1
times 3 which is negative three one
times two which is two and notice this
is an improper fraction the numerator is
larger than the denominator so 2 goes
into three one whole time
with one left over so this becomes one
and one half and you can see it's
negative so negative one and one half is
our final answer as a mixed number
for number 18 now what would you do on
this one we have a mixed number times a
mixed number
well the first thing that I would do is
I would convert these into improper
fractions and the way you do that is you
take the denominator times the whole
number plus the numerator so 5 times 2
is 10 plus 2 is 12 all divided by that
same denominator 5.
times three times one is three plus two
is five all over that same denominator
3. now we can multiply horizontally
across and then reduce but sometimes
it's helpful to kind of like pre-reduce
or cross cancel that kind of thing I can
see that these two fives five goes in
there once 5 goes in there once 3 goes
in here once and three goes in here four
times now when I multiply across four
times one is equal to four one times one
is equal to one anything divided by one
is itself so we're just getting 4. okay
and for number 19 now we're dividing two
mixed numbers what did you get on that
problem well again I would convert these
into
improper fractions first so I'd say 3
times 3 is 9 plus 2 is 11. so we're
looking at eleven thirds and this whole
thing is negative
and over here
5 times 2 is 10 plus 1 is 11 all over
that same denominator 5. when we divide
or we do the keep it change it flip it
so you keep the first fraction you
change this to multiplication and you
take the reciprocal of the second
fraction we can reduce here on the
diagonal 11 goes in here negative 1
times 11 goes in here once and now when
I multiply across I get negative 5 over
3. notice the numerator is larger than
the denominator 3 goes into 5 one whole
time with two left over so that's one
and two thirds and you can see this
whole quantity is negative so you should
get negative one and two-thirds okay are
you still with me
so now we're going to be talking about
decimal operations so how do you work
with decimals see if you can pause the
video and do these four problems and
we'll go through them together so for
number 20 what did you get for this one
3.42
plus 1.9 now when I'm adding and
subtracting decimals what I like to do
is I like to put them one above another
so I'm going to bring this 1.9 right
here and what you want to do is you want
to
line up the decimal points this way
you're adding the units the tenths the
hundredths so you're adding the
of same types of quantities so we've got
two plus zero which is two four plus
nine is thirteen so I'm going to put the
3 carry the one bring down the decimal
point one plus three plus one is five so
you can see we're getting
5.32 or you could say 5 and 32
hundredths since this last place is in
the hundreds place
for number 21 now we're subtracting and
when I'm subtracting I like to change it
to an addition problem so subtraction is
really like adding the opposite
now notice we have more negatives than
we have positives so we're going to end
up with a negative number and we want to
ask ourselves how many more negatives do
we have than positives
which is really like saying we need to
subtract when you take the large number
minus a smaller number so what I'm going
to do here is I'm just going to take
8.62
minus 4 and I know that because I have
more negatives than positives my final
answer is going to be negative okay and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to subtract and if you don't have any
numbers here you can put some
placeholder zeros so 2 minus 0 is 2 6
minus zero is six eight minus four is
four I'm just going to bring that
decimal point straight down so it comes
out to a negative 4.62
okay for number 22 now you can see these
two quantities are next to each other
with nothing in between that means
they're multiplied together and when you
multiply decimals you don't have to
worry about lining up the decimal points
you can basically think about this like
as if you're multiplying uh just like
two whole numbers together you can even
think of it as just like multiplying 31
times 25 okay
so we say 5 times 1 is 5 5 times 3 is 15
then we put a placeholder zero two times
one is two two times three is six we add
straight down that's five seven seven
and then what we do is we count the
number of decimal places so we won one
that's a total of two decimal places so
from this end we move it two to the left
so that comes out to
7.75 but notice we have a negative times
a positive which is a negative
okay so good job if you got that one and
then for number 23 here we're doing some
division so we have a negative 4.214
divided by 0.7 so here what I would do
is I would underneath the
division bar let's go ahead and put the
4.214 divided by 0.7 now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to move this decimal
point one place to the right to make
this a whole number it's just going to
be like 7 now and if I move this one
place to the right I have to move this
decimal one place to the right so that
becomes like 42.14 I'm going to bring
that decimal point up on the division
bar
and now I'm just asking myself how many
times does 7 go into 4 well it doesn't
how many times does 7 go into 42 that's
6 times and when I distribute 6 times 7
is 42 and if I subtract I'm left with 14
does 7 go into 1 no
so that's a 0 to 7 going to 14 yes how
many times 2 times 2 times 7 is 14. zero
remainder we have a negative divided by
a positive which is going to be a
negative number so you should be getting
negative 6.02 now sometimes when I do
this moving the decimal place like that
I would go ahead and then rewrite it I
would say like 7 is going into
42.14 a little bit easier to look at and
then you want to keep everything lined
up like the decimal point and when you
bring the numbers down so that in this
case you see we had a placeholder here
we had a zero because 7 didn't go into
1. so you just have to be a little bit
careful with the division
okay now moving on to working with
exponents see if you can do these
problems on your own
for number 24 what did you get for this
one 5 to the zero power now sometimes
students get a little bit confused they
see that zero and they think oh it's
zero or maybe it's five but you wanna
remember anything to the zero power is
always equal to one
okay for number 25 now we've got a
negative exponent what do you do on this
one well when you see a negative
exponent that tells us to take the
reciprocal you can do this a couple
different ways you could write this as
one over six to the positive 2 which 6
squared means 6 times 6 like 6 twice
that's 1 36 or what you could do is you
could say 6 squared is 36 and then take
the reciprocal and get 136 either way
you get the same answer
for number 26 9 to the first Power what
did you get for that one well anything
to the first power is always itself it
just means you have one of them so
that's just nine
and for 27 and 28 these look very
similar to one another notice here we
have negative 2 in parentheses to the
sixth power here we don't have any
parentheses so what did you get on those
two well I can think of this as negative
times negative two times negative 2 like
6 times right
and for every two negatives I'm going to
get a positive positive positive so if
you have an even number of negatives
multiplied together you're going to get
a positive so I know the answer here is
positive I just have to do 2 times 2 is
4 4 times 2 is 8 8 times 2 is 16 16
times 2 is 32 32 times 2 is 64 and this
is a positive 64.
for number 28 though I have to follow
that order of operations that PEMDAS so
I really have to do the exponents before
I do the multiplication whereas over
here I had to do the parentheses first
before I did the exponents that's why I
treated that whole quantity as a group
so if I do the 2 to the sixth power 2
times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2.
see 6 2 is multiplied together I get 64.
that's this quantity right here then
times the negative is going to give us a
negative 64. so you want to watch that
order of operations
okay now moving on to absolute value
that's what these vertical bars
represent how would you do these three
problems here see if you can pause the
video and try those
now if I was going to do this negative 3
the absolute value this is just going to
come out to positive 3. absolute value
is like the distance from 0 on the
number line so if here's zero if I go
left 3 that's really still a distance of
3 units it's kind of like if you ran
three miles backwards it still counts as
three miles right
now let's go to number 30 the absolute
value of 7. again if we think of that
number line here's 0 7 is going to be 7
to the right but you're like seven units
away from the origin or the starting
point that's also going to be 7. some
students make the mistake of thinking
that absolute value means the opposite
that's not quite right it means that
it's always going to make it into a
positive quantity and then for number 31
you can treat the absolute value bars
just like we did the parentheses in the
order of operations the PEMDAS so I can
do what's inside here first negative 4
times 3 is negative 12 because the
negative times a positive is a negative
then the absolute value of negative 12
is saying hmm how far am I from that
origin or that zero or that starting
point and again remember we know that
this always makes this into a positive
value
so positive 12 is your answer on that
one okay moving on now to simplifying
expressions as well as using the
distributive property see if you can
simplify these four go ahead and pause
the video and we'll go through them
together
now for number 32 how did you do that
one well you can see this negative 2 is
on the outside of the parentheses
and it's really next to the parentheses
with nothing in between that means
multiplication so here's where we're
going to distribute which is another way
of saving you're multiplying that
quantity into the parentheses now here's
where students go a little bit off track
you want to treat this negative 2 as a
group you also want to treat this 5x as
a group you also want to treat this
minus 8 like as a negative 8 or a group
so you've got negative 2 times 5x which
is a negative 10x and a negative 2 times
a negative 8 is a positive 16 so that's
plus 16. so remember minus and negative
go together plus and positive go
together and you always want to try to
capture that sign that comes to the left
or in front of the number so if you see
a minus think of it as a negative if you
see a plus think of it as a positive if
you don't see anything to the left or in
front that means it's a positive
okay so for number 33
what did you get on this one now you can
see there's a fraction sometimes
students freak out a little bit when
they see fractions here's how you can
get around that any whole number can be
written as a fraction by putting it over
the number one because anything divided
by one is itself so now when we
distribute this 1 4 into the parentheses
you multiply the numerators together and
the denominators together so 1 times 20
is 20. 4 times 1 is 4. 1 times negative
6 is negative 6 Y and 4 times 1 is 4.
now we can do a little bit of reducing
20 divided by 4 is 5.
6 and 4 2 goes into four twice 2 goes
into six three times so we're getting
minus three halves y or minus three y
over two either one of those is correct
now for 34 and 35 what did you get on
these ones now again like I was saying
in the the first problem there you want
to capture
the sign whether it's positive or
negative so when I see a minus sign in
my mind I I captured I group it with
that quantity you can draw circles
around that if it helps eventually
you'll kind of just know that this
negative is stuck to this 2 this
negative is stuck to the seven this plus
means a positive like that you can think
of them as being on sheets of like
little paper and you can move them
around and group The like terms together
so I can see negative 2A and positive 6A
that adds up to 4A and I can see that 5
plus negative 7 that adds up to negative
2 which is like minus two and you got it
for 45 35 I mean this one's a little bit
more challenging but we can still do it
we see a minus 2. I'm going to think of
this as a negative 2. I'm going to
distribute it into the parentheses so
that gives us negative 2 times 3x which
is a negative 6X and negative 2 times a
negative 6 is a positive 12 or plus 12
then I'm just going to bring down the 4
and the X now we're back to this type of
problem where we're just combining like
terms if you want you can Circle them
and think of them as you know a group
capture the sign negative 6X plus 1X is
negative 5X
and 4 plus 12 is 16. and you got it okay
now we're moving on to solving equations
we'll start off with one step equations
and two-step equations then multi-step
equations so see if you can pause the
video on these three and then we're
gonna have some more challenging ones in
the next three after this so for 36 what
did you get on this one
well when I think of solving equations
you might want to make a note of this if
you're kind of struggling with solving
equations I think of it as three steps
the first step is I think of simplifying
the left side as much as I can
simplifying the right side then step
number two is I try to get the variables
on one side and the numbers on the
opposite side and then the third step is
you just want to solve for one of the
variables so One X or one y like that
so in this case we really can't simplify
anything here because we have a variable
and a number
but I want to get the numbers on one
side variables on the other side I
already have the X on the left that
means I want to get this number here on
the right to get this number on the
right I have to get rid of it on the
left by doing the opposite so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to instead of
subtracting 4 I'm going to add 4 because
that's going to cancel and give me zero
and then I get 6 plus 4 is 10. now the
nice thing about algebra and solving
equations is you can take this number 10
put it back into the original problem
and see if it equals 6 to check your
work
for number 37 we've got 5x equals 20. of
course we always want to just solve for
one of the variable so I say well these
guys are multiplied together the
opposite of multiplying by 5 is to
divide both sides by five five divided
by 5 is 1 and we get X is equal to 20
divided by 5 which is 4 and you got it
now for 38 this one's a little bit more
challenging we have a fraction
two-fifths x equals 30.
we want to get this x by itself you can
see this is multiply by two-fifths we
could divide both sides by two-fifths
but when you have a fraction like this
sometimes it's easier to instead of
divide multiply by the reciprocal so I'm
going to multiply by 5 over 2. now the
reason this works is because C of 5
divided by 5 is 1 2 divided by two is
one we get that variable X by itself we
can think of 30 as 30 over 1. we can do
some cross reducing 2 goes in here once
2 goes in here 15 times
15 times 5 is 75 over 1
and anything divided by one is itself so
you can see X is coming out to 75. okay
see if you can do these next four
problems again solving equations see if
you can find out what x equals go ahead
and pause the video if I was going to do
number 39 what I would do is I would
think of those three steps I mentioned
earlier I would see if I can simplify
the left side or the right side which in
this case I can then I would try to get
the variables on one side numbers on the
other so in this case the variables on
the left so let me get the numbers on
the right by getting rid of the numbers
on the left so I'm doing the opposite
instead of adding one I'm subtracting 1
so that gives me 3x equals 18 and then I
just want to solve for one of the
variables so instead of multiplying by 3
let me divide both sides by 3 to keep it
balanced whatever you do to the left you
want to do to the right so X is coming
out to 6. again you can check your work
by putting it back in for x and
simplifying and making sure you get
equal 19. okay for number 40 what did
you get on this one
now this one's a little bit different
notice the variables are on the right so
let me get the numbers here on the left
so instead of adding 3 let me subtract 3
for both sides
and that's going to give me negative 5x
is equal to negative 15 instead of
multiplying by negative 5. let's divide
both sides by negative 5 and X is coming
out to positive 3.
for 41
a little bit more challenging what did
you get on this one well here I can see
that I'm going to have to distribute
that 3 into the parentheses so I get 3y
minus 12 minus y equals 10. so I'm just
simplifying the left side I can simplify
a little bit further 3y minus y gives us
2y
now I simplify the left side and right
side as much as I can so going down to
step number two I want to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
other so I'm going to add 12 to both
sides
keep it balanced so 2y is equal to 22
and then lastly I just want to solve for
one of the variable so I'm going to
divide both sides by 2
Y is equal to 11 and then for number 42
what did you get on this one I would
distribute the 5 and distribute the 3 so
I'll just simplify the left side and the
right side as much as you can
now we want to get the variables on one
side numbers on the other it doesn't
matter which side I'm going to get the
variables on the right so that means I'm
going to get rid of them on the left by
doing the opposite
so that gives us x minus 3. now I've got
the variables on the right that means I
want to get the numbers on the left so
to get them on the left I have to get
rid of them on the right by doing the
opposite
so now we have X is equal to negative 10
plus 3 which is negative 7 and you got
it okay moving on to solving
inequalities see if you can pause the
video and do these three examples if I
was going to do it for number 43 it's
just like solving equations you want to
you know get the variables on one side
numbers on the other
and you want to solve for just one of
the variables some of the divide both
sides by six so you can see that X is
greater than 2. that's our solution now
if you want to graph it on the number
line Here's 2
and it's everything that's greater than
2. now not equal to 2 so I'm making that
an open circle like Hollow but
everything that's greater than or to the
right of two and that would be like a
whole set of solutions
now for number 44 what I'm going to do
is I'm going to get the variables on one
side numbers on the other so I'm going
to add 4X to both sides
so that comes out to negative x minus 3
is less than or equal to 2. I'm going to
add 3 to both sides
keep that balance we have Negative X is
less than or equal to 5. I want to solve
for 1X I'm going to divide both sides by
negative 1. so X is
negative 5. now when you multiply or
divide both sides by a negative number
what happens is the inequality sign
flips it changes Direction it doesn't
matter if you add or subtract a negative
number or if there's a negative number
in the problem just if you yourself
multiply or divide both sides by a
negative that sign flips so this is our
solution now if we graph it on the
number line say here's negative 5 it's
equal to negative 5. so we're going to
make this a closed Circle and everything
that's greater than or to the right of
negative 5.
and then for number 45 what we're going
to do is we're going to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
other
so we have negative 4X and this is 20.
divide both sides by negative 4 to get X
by itself
remember when you multiply or divide by
a negative number this inequality sign
is going to change directions but notice
our variables on the right with
inequalities you want to get the
variable on the left so I'm going to
pick up this whole inequality and flip
it over
so now we have X is less than or equal
to negative 5. so if here's negative 5
it's equal to negative 5 or anything
less than or to the left of negative 5
and you got it okay now moving on to
translating sentences into equations or
inequalities that's going to be these
two problems and then solving some
proportions that's going to be these two
problems see if you can pause the video
and do these problems on your own
so this first one it says two more than
the product of 4 and a number is 10. so
how do we translate that into an
equation or an inequality well if I was
going to do that 2 more than the product
of 4 and a number is 10. so product
means multiplication so 4 times n or we
can just put them next to each other
that means they're multiplied together
so the product of four and a number is
4N 2 more than that means that I'm
adding 2. when you see the word is that
means equals
10 and that would be your equation you
don't have to solve it we'll just leave
it like that for now
for 47 how would you do this one three
less than the difference of eight and a
number is at least 12. three less than
the difference of eight and a number is
at least 12. now if I was going to do
this one the difference of eight and a
number means 8 minus n the difference
means like subtraction okay and then 3
less than that means you're taking away
three now some students what they do is
they say oh three less than they say 3
minus but it's 3 less that means you're
taking away three from this quantity now
is at least 12 at at least means that
it's greater than or equal to 12. some
people say the word least and they think
of less than but at least means that
much or more so greater than or equal to
and that's that one so for 48 and 49 how
did you solve these proportions how did
you do these ones
well you can do this a couple different
ways you could say like how am I getting
from eight to two like I'm dividing by
four so if I take 20 divided by 4 x
would be 5 that's one way to do it
probably not the most favorite way but
that's a quick way the other way that
students like to do it is use this cross
product method so you say 8 times x is
8x
equals 2 times 20 which is 40. now we
can just solve this equation divide both
sides by eight
and you can see X is equal to 5. so
that's called the cross product or the
means extremes property so for 49 let's
do that same thing 10y
is equal to 3 times 7 which is 21.
divide both sides by 10 to get y by
itself Y is equal to 21 over 10 10 goes
into 21 twice with 1 left over so you
can write it as a mixed number 2 and 1
10. okay moving on to percentage
problems now see if you can do these
three problems go ahead and pause the
video and if you want to use a
calculator on these three problems you
can go ahead and do that I hope you've
been trying to do most of them without a
calculator as we go through
uh but for number 50 it says what is 20
of 12. now a nice neat way to solve
these problems is what we call the
percent proportion so you say p over 100
is equal to is over of what does that
mean it means the percent is like the
part out of a hundred the part out of
the whole hundreds like the whole amount
equals is which is the part out of which
is the whole so we have part out of the
whole equals the part out of the whole
so the way I would apply that is what is
okay so I don't know what this is I'm
going to say x 20 that's 20 Parts out of
100 20 percent okay of meaning out of
the total 12. so we've got the part over
the whole equals the part over the whole
now you can cross multiply and solve
and that's a good way to do it if you're
just using a calculator you could also
reduce so I can see 20 and 100 reduced
to 1 over 5. so now when I cross
multiply I get 5x is equal to 12. so 5x
is equal to 12. divide both sides by 5.
and I can see that X is coming out to 2
and 2 5 or as a decimal that's going to
be 2.4
now for 51 how would you do this one 18
is what percent of 90. so again if we go
back to this percent proportion
what percent we don't know so let's just
call this P since we don't know the
percentage over 100 18 is what percent
out of that's the total C90
. now again you can reduce a little bit
you can say 18 goes in here once 18 goes
in here five times now when I cross
multiply 5p is equal to 100
so divide by 5 you can see that P is
equal to 20. so that would be 20 percent
so 18 is 20 of 90. and then for this
last one number 52 6 is 12 of what
number well 12 percent is 12 Parts out
of 100 the part over the whole 6 is
that's six of what number we don't know
the number we'll just call that X now
this one you can cross multiply or you
could reduce and then cross multiply or
you could say 12 divided by 2 is 6.
100 divided by 2 is 50. so this would be
50. and you got it okay now moving on to
the greatest common factor and the least
common multiple the GCF or the LCM so
how would you do that for number 53 and
54. go ahead and find the greatest
common factor as well as the least
common multiple for these numbers and
then these numbers now if I was going to
do it
there's a couple different ways to do it
but I'm going to show you the way that I
like which is to make a prime
factorization tree so I'm going to take
8 and 12 I'm going to break them down
into their prime numbers so 4 times 2 is
8 and 4 is 2 times 2. so this is really
like 2 to the third power since we have
three twos multiplied together 12 is 6
times 2 and 6 is 3 times 2. so here what
we have is we have two twos so that's
two squared times three to the first so
I've just broken the numbers down now
when you do the greatest common factor
you actually take what occurs not the
greatest but the least so you say I've
got three twos here two twos here so I
take
two twos
and then I have no threes here one three
here I take what occurs not the greatest
but the least which is no threes so 2
squared is going to come out to four so
our greatest common factor is four what
that means it's the largest number that
goes into both 8 and 12 evenly so if you
were reducing a fraction like say if it
was 8 12 you could divide the top by
four the Bottom by four and reduce that
fraction with that greatest common
factor now if I do the least common
multiple I take not what occurs the
least but the most so if I say I have
got three twos two twos I'm going to
take the one that occurs the most 1 3 no
threes I take the one that occurs the
most 2 cubed is eight times three to the
first 8 times 3 is 24. so our least
common multiple is 24. now we would use
the least common multiple if we were
getting common denominators so imagine
if you're adding two fractions you say
what's my common denominator it's the
least common multiple you'd want to get
a denominator of 24. so those are the
applications or some of the applications
of
greatest common factor and least common
multiple so how did you do number 54
well let's go ahead and do the prime
factorization 3 times 5
40 is going to be 8 times 5 8 is 4 times
2 and 4 is 2 times 2. so you can see
that we've got 3 to the first times 5 to
the first here we have 2 to the third we
have three twos and one five and if I'm
doing the greatest common factor I'm
going to take not the greatest but what
occurs the least so I've got three twos
no twos so I don't want any twos
no threes one three so I don't want any
threes one five one five I take the one
that occurs the least which is just one
five so our greatest common factor is
five
for the least common multiple I take not
the one that occurs the least but the
most so I've got two threes no I said
they're wrong three twos no twos so I
take the one that occurs the most which
is three twos one three no threes I take
the larger one which is one three one
five one five it's a tie so I just take
one five so that's eight times three is
twenty four times five is a hundred and
twenty that's going to be your least
common multiple and you got it
okay as we approach the end of this
algebra Readiness review slash practice
I just wanted to mention a couple things
before we do these last four problems
one is if you like the way that I
explain things and you're going into
algebra or reviewing algebra check out
in the description below my algebra 1
video course for sale as well as my
algebra 2 slash college algebra video
course for sale I've got the links down
below the other thing is if you went
through these topics and you thought I
still want more practice with you know
reviewing to get ready for algebra I'll
have at this end of the video and I'll
indicate a pre-algebra final exam review
video that's for free here on YouTube
and I'll put a link to that where you
can go through more explanation more
practice problems even more topics than
we covered here if you want to do some
more learning and some more practice so
check that out so let's go ahead and do
these last four problems so for 55 and
56 see if you can find the perimeter in
the area of these figures and for 57 and
58 see if you can take the square roots
of these two numbers
now for 55 remember perimeter what does
that mean it means if you walk around
the outer edge of this object what's the
distance that you travel this is a
rectangle and I guess I could have done
a little bit better job of indicating
that
but you can see that the opposite sides
are going to be congruent so four
centimeters and two centimeters so if I
add up all those sides that comes out to
12 centimeters and we're just using
centimeters because it's just distance
or length or one dimensional
area for a rectangle is length times
width or base times height or this side
times this side 4 times 2 comes out to
eight
centimeters squared so that's a square
units it's area it's two dimensional
for 56 we have a triangle again the
perimeter is if we walk around the outer
edge so 5 plus 5 plus 6 that comes out
to 16 inches but the area for a triangle
is one half the base times the height so
the base is the bottom kind of what it
sits on here
and the height is how tall it is that's
that perpendicular distance which is
four six times four is 24 times a half
is 12. inches squared because it's area
two dimensional
and then for 57 this little symbol here
is the square root symbol it's saying
what number times itself equals 49 well
7 times 7 is 49 so that's the square
root of 49 just 7. and 58 the square
root of 100 what number times itself is
100 that's going to be 10. and you got
it so great job let me know how you did
with this review leave a comment in the
description box below and if you want
more practice follow me over to that
pre-algebra final exam review where I go
into a lot more topics some of the same
ones here but some additional ones as
well I'll see you over in that video